hey every morning sale with register
nurse orient calm and in this video
we're going to talk about common reasons
people miss veins whenever they're
drawing blood and especially starting
IVs now you are a new nurse you will
probably face this dilemma unless you've
been in the health care setting and
you've been exposed to this type of
skill because starting IVs and drawing
blood it is a skill that you learn and
in nursing school my nursing school
anyways we really weren't given a lot of
opportunities to practice and practice
IVs it was something that I learned as a
new nurse how to do so in this video I'm
going to give you some reasons why why
you miss and I'm going to go over how to
increase your success rate because
whenever you're working as a nurse one
of the things that you must know how to
do is to get an IV because you can't
always depend on someone to do it for
you especially if the IVs blown on you
and you go to get the patient to get a
get a test because they're getting a CT
with P protocol you got to get an 18 and
a C or you have an antibiotic that needs
to be given or the patient's in pain and
they need some IV medication and
everyone's busy so it's a skill that you
just have to have so what I want to do
first let's go over the reasons why
people miss one of the biggest reasons
especially for me whenever I first
started out as a nurse with that I
didn't really know how all the supplies
worked because you have butterflies you
have straight needles like this one then
you have a saline flush and then you
have the part that you connect and you
flush with the connector and there's
just so much to do with one hand after
you actually stick the patient so what I
recommend is that you really learn your
supplies and one thing that a lot of
people have trouble with I want to show
you this is that whenever they're
starting the IV C on the
me you have this plastic cannula that's
what you're seeing right there and once
you hit the vein you get a nice flash of
blood in here you'll see red and that's
great you hit the vein but that's not
the whole part to it you have to slide
this cannula into the bank and that's a
big thing that messes a lot of people I
know I have lost a lot of IVs because I
couldn't slide this in but how to use
your supplies take it out play with it
see how it works because that's going to
increase your success rate next and you
kicked too small of a vein whatever
you're first starting out you really
number one you don't know where to look
and you don't know whenever you see it
and you're like hey that works I found
the vein but you have to make sure that
it's big enough it's going to hold the
cannula size that you're going to insert
and that it's going to hold if you're
gonna be giving a lot of fluids if
you're going to be giving best can't
drug fight vinegar in any odor in or
things like that that it's going to work
so you have to know to pick a good vein
next you don't know where to look and
especially when you're first starting
out it's like well I see a lot of
patients with them in their AC so that
must be the place to work but there's a
lot of great other places on the arm to
look just um other than the AC and you
didn't prepare the vein properly the key
to being very successful at getting your
IV is that you've got to make that vein
go from flat to puff it up because it's
hard to hit something that's flat and
not engorge then it is hit something
that's literally popping right at you so
in my previous videos I've really talked
about that I've talked about putting the
tourniquet on I have a video on how to
properly put on a tourniquet because
this is going to cause resistance and
increase the blood or decrease the blood
flow to your arm so it's going to cause
all the blood to pull in that vein and
really puff it up and then also once you
get the veining gorge if it's a rolling
vein which we just covered that how to
stabilize it
one tip is that especially in handbags
because they like to roll you want to
hold your finger above the insertion
point and just sort of pull a little bit
time before you actually go in so the
vein won't roll to the side and move on
you and another reason is like I said
the bank roll or it blue usually what
happens whenever it blows this can
happen on anyone and some reasons is
maybe you shouldn't use your tourniquet
if you get men who are really cardio
athletic they work out they run a lot
they have beautiful veins and typically
if that vein is already puffed up there
you don't have have to use a tourniquet
because when you're using a tourniquet
you're already putting so much
resistance on that vein that whenever
you go to poke it with a needle it's in
a sense like you're poking a balloon and
it's too much pressure on it it's just
want to sort of just collapse and or
you've picked too small of a vein again
and it just couldn't hold that saline
flush that you have to flush in behind
it so you want to make sure that you try
to prevent that from happening next the
biggest thing is having no confidence of
starting IVs is 2% skill and it's 90%
mental I remember one of my first
started I was a nurse the first year I
was horrible at IVs I got to a point
where I would literally just call
someone say hey I need an IV because I
knew if I went in there and try to start
it I went and get it but then after a
while I was four so I was like fair
you've got to learn how to do this so I
started doing it started increasing my
success rate I started talking with
other nurses asking them for tips of how
to increase my success rate and I
started getting them and once I started
getting all my IVs I have like a 95 to
98% success rate and so once I started
getting them my confidence went up and
it was really hard for me to miss a vein
so it's all about what you think about
yourself up in here and last but not
least some patients just don't have
anything and this is what you need look
for in a patient is a diabetic
has congestive heart failure renal
failure has had chemo in the past or
they've been an IV
drug user they may be really hard to
stick for drawing blood or for getting
an IV and these patients may be a
candidate for a central line which
you'll have to go to doctor's order for
but keep that in mind so don't bum
yourself out if you're working on a
renal floor or if you're working on a
congestive heart failure floor just know
but those patients have really limited
access for bein so don't beat yourself
up now let's talk about how to increase
your success rate okay when to use a
tourniquet and when not to use a
tourniquet remember how I talked about
with flowing vein and if they had really
if the veins were already engorge them
big already you don't need to use a
tourniquet because like I said it's like
taking a needle to a balloon it's going
to pop so don't use a tourniquet on
those but sometimes some people don't
use the tourniquets correctly they put
it on too loose they don't get that bang
popped up because one of the biggest
things is making sure that vein is
visible for you to see or to feel and I
really recommend that the best way to
learn how to fill veins is to feel on
yourself or a boyfriend a wife or
whoever because you've got a vein feels
like some it specifically has a feeling
to it compared to like a tendon urn or
like a nerve or some tissue so what I
recommend is like maybe get a tourniquet
make a little tourniquet and just feel
on your own vein get the feeling of how
it feels because that's really how you
start them is by where you feel it's at
next and another thing of helping get
that vein engorge is that you want that
person to dangle their arm and pump
their fist because that's increasing
resistance like putting a taking a water
hose that has water running to it and
kinking it and not water hoses going to
start to swell that's like the same
concept is what's happening to those
veins and you want that to happen so you
can increase your chances of getting
them um next ask the patient where's the
best spot to stick you because patients
one of them they've been in the hospital
a lot they go and get blood drawn
regularly and they know there are sweet
spots so ask them say hey I'm going to
start an IV on you where do people
normally
get it or where can I get it and this
has helped me so much because patients
know their bodies a lot better than we
do and next pick a good vein in a
popular spot popular spots that usually
have great vein are the antecubital area
which is this area up in here and the
hand typically the forearm isn't my
favorite some people love it but they
tend to be a little bit deep that you
have muscles that run along there but
the AC and the hands are great so always
look there first so whenever you're
practicing feeling on your own veins
feel there and usually in every human
the veins are in the same location cuz
rolled is on the same another thing is
to stabilize that vein please watch my
video on how to prevent a rolling vein
because that's one of the biggest
reasons people miss is cuz they go in
they didn't stabilize that vein from
rolling and it moved I like to compare
it to this say you're fishing and you're
trying to hook a worm onto your fishing
hook so you can finish well you have the
worm it's movie and you're trying to get
the hook you're going to have to hold
and stabilize that worm before you can
hook it and it's the same concept with a
vein you've got to hold that vein and
stabilize it in that video I'll go over
how to do that so check that out and
next learn your equipment and some
people they love to use butterflies I'm
not a butterfly person I think it takes
too much hand work and I'm a straight I
like to use a straight ID which is what
I just showed you so learn how your
equipment works and learn how to use one
hand when you're having to peel that
tape when you're having to pump that
tourniquet off and everything because
that's really the hard part about
starting IV you're drawing blood is that
you only have one hand to work with so
practice and last but not least practice
practice practice it took me about a
year to get good at I've even if I
didn't practice I wouldn't got your data
so even though if you totally sink at
them and you're not good steel practice
because I promise you will learn it's
something you have to learn it's not
something we're born with it's something
that you got to practice so I hope that
helped you out
on common reasons people miss thanks
thank you so much for watching and
please check out my other YouTube videos
and subscribe to this youtube channel